hey what's up guys my name is Archana
and Cherno chat is over that series is
complete it is the first series that I
have ever completed on my channel and
I'm feeling pretty happy and proud about
that now
this is gonna be like a post Cherno chat
kind of let's reflect on what we've done
let's reflect on what we've learned and
and where to go next kind of thing okay
because I thought that um obviously the
last episode which was episode 31 which
went up about nine hours ago actually
exactly nine hours ago that that video
it was kind of like a finishing up some
it's um like like I I guess just
cleaning up a server a bit and getting
all that stuff worked out and we didn't
really end the series on kind of like a
this is the finale kind of thing right
and I wanted um I really wanted to do
that so this video is kind of like the
bonus video that will that will explain
to you guys where to go next essentially
okay so um first of all we've got this
Cherno chat git repository okay and
that's oh that's freaking awesome okay
and this this repository has all of the
source code you could ever want okay in
need - hi world all the source code that
you could ever want for China chat okay
and this um the reason I say all of it
is because this doesn't just include
stuff like the most up-to-date one which
of course is episode 31 so you can see
that in episode 31 we did a few things
like adding help text for the client if
I click on the server - Java class you
can say that there is that help text
that we did everything here is up to
date okay you can download this you can
do whatever you want with this the only
license that the rest of this I haven't
actually added a license formally should
do that but the only license that there
is what this is that if you do use it
then just make sure that you mentioned
that you didn't write it
okay simple as that but really write
what I want to kind of give you guys the
opportunity to do is expand on this
right that's one of the things I was
really excited about as well right there
are a lot of features that that people
have kind of requested for me to do and
and I haven't done them okay one of the
most recent ones for example is the
online users thing now I actually did do
that okay because I thought it was a
great idea and I thought that you know
what that's something that I think will
will
from the base of other kind of
extensions that people might want to do
for this so that's why I did the online
users dot Java kind of thing here and
you can see it right over here
okay and I did that thing and I made it
work properly and that was of course in
episode 30 but the idea is that there
are so many things that you guys want to
add to this okay there are so many
things for example there's private
messaging there's other there's
different permissions different roles so
that there might be moderators that can
ban people banning people all of that
stuff right and I haven't done that
because if I did this serious would go
on forever because there's an unlimited
amount of things that we can add we can
add emoticons we can add so many things
that are just gonna be ridiculous okay
we can add a formal login okay a formal
login so in other words that would
authenticate you through an SQL database
make sure that of course your password
is correct that would be relatively
simple to do of course but I didn't
cover that stuff um anyway the idea is
that there are so many things that that
you could do that I haven't done okay
and because of that I want you guys to
kind of continue this series okay if
that makes any sense at all probably
does but I want you guys to continue the
series okay so what I want you guys to
do if you want of course is feel free
right feel absolutely free to just go
ahead and take this source code and make
stuff out of it okay and what I mean by
that is extend upon Turner Turner shot
an episode 31 this is what it looks like
okay and that that's the representation
of this I'm not actually showing you
guys what this looks like but that's
that this code is what it that's where
it's at okay if you guys want to add
stuff to it you can do that okay if you
sign up for a github a github account
account I can't even talk today if you
stand up for a github account you can
actually fork this this repper get this
repository you can fork it what that
means is you're gonna copy this and it's
gonna create a new repository for you
okay and then you can add your changes
to it so in other words you can see
you're actually eleven people have
already folks it which is a bloody good
idea if I click on the eleven I think
it'll UM take me to these people
potentially members maybe yeah okay yeah
so you can see all these wonderful users
here have forked it so if I click on
blue blue biz just the best name ever so
you can see that he's got his own
tarnish out
buzzer train instead of being a full
slash of the churner right being instead
of being false laughter the Cherno turns
out it's just full-sized lube full sized
furniture this is under his control now
okay and he's only gotten up to episode
three unfortunately here but the idea is
you guys can fork it okay and I'll go
back to I'll go back to where are we the
chair shot but the idea is you guys can
[ __ ] that and that'll basically just
make a copy of this for you to use and
you can do you can make your changes to
it and it'll be on github for it for
everyone to see if you need help with
setting that up let me know I might make
you video of this video kind of gets
popular and that'll guide you
essentially guide you how to essentially
extend upon this series by creating a
github repository and then cloning it
and then I'm going ahead and and using
get with that if you guys want that
leave a comment below I'd be glad to do
that
okay I've actually got to github
tutorials they'll be in the description
below check them out if you aren't
familiar with github that should help
you get started but if you want this
[ __ ] stuff I'll do it for you guys
okay
because I'm really excited about what we
can do with this now uh what else was I
gonna say yeah so go ahead make make
some of the stuff that you wanted to be
in it and an updated to your github
repository now if you get stuck if you
need help with this kind of stuff
don't fret and the reason I say that is
because on the channel calm the place
where dreams are made we have a we have
a network chat programming sort of
subreddit I was gonna say forum okay now
watch a programming and in here put a
bunch of posts of courses relate to the
series feel free to make new topics here
right if you if you are if you log in
I'm actually already logged in but if
you log in and you go ahead and and and
it'll obviously when it wants to make an
account if you register a log in you'll
be able to post this form so if you do
that you'll be able to create new topics
you'll be able to talk about stuff that
you want to add um and then if maybe you
want to add something like private
messages and you're like okay here's my
github repository here's where I've
gotten up to I really want to implement
this I need help then this is a place to
get it right and then all you guys can
kind of collaborate and make these these
epic um these these epic I guess
extensions or I don't know what you want
to go in add-ons blue plugins anything
for fortune our chat okay there'll be a
few more episodes coming out that'll
kind of demonstrate the usability of
Trinidad I know I know a lot of people
are unclear of how it works unless
they've actually run it for themselves
and just for convenience I'm actually
gonna put out a video probably tomorrow
or so that will show you guys it running
on like a clock it'll be like a kind of
vlog video and I'll show you how it runs
kind of on different computers on
different networks whatever and then
also I want to I want to kind of show
you guys how to set it up on like a
Linux server as well because obviously
this has this has a server client
architecture and you probably want to
set it up on a Linux server that's one
of the reasons why while writing in in
Java is so easy right you can just want
and on Linux with no problem at all
okay obviously with C and C++ you can do
that as well but it won't work out of
the box if you've been making it on
Windows and stuff like that Java will
okay anyway that those videos are gonna
come soon after but this kind of plug-in
development stuff that's what I really
wanted to talk to you guys about now
let's talk about um where the series
leads right so now that now that is done
we in my in my opinion kind of I don't
know yet because I haven't really
planned this ahead I kind of you know me
I just kind of spontaneously attack life
here but I think that we've covered
pretty much everything we need to cover
multiplayer in in game programming okay
so I've got another series on my channel
most of you are aware of it's called
game programming and the game that we're
making is realm of the mad God which is
an MMO thus we need this kind of this
kind of server client architecture that
deals with you UDP packets okay rather
than rather than TCP that's why I made
this chat in UDP okay now um that being
said I think we're pretty much ready to
implement them multiplayer stuff to game
programming that was kind of why this
series why I first created it okay and
then what I did I was kind of having a
lot of fun with it making a track line
it's always fun so um I thought that you
know what I'll just I'll continue this
series and make it you know a lot more
expansive so stuff like online uses an a
proper interface and all that stuff but
other than that you
but you know that's pretty much it right
that's that's that's kind of where the
series is gonna lead into it's gonna
lead into a smooth transition into game
programming eventually not not now okay
I think we're up to episode 102 at the
time of me making this video when we get
to observe 120 or so I want to implement
a few more things a lot more things
first actually like inventory and all
that stuff and like a menu system
probably yeah definitely actually so
that we can connect to the server
properly
Alfred all that stuff multiplayer will
be covered and an internet chat will be
the basis of how that how that
multiplier is set up okay simple as that
now I think that's pretty much all I
wanted to talk about yes there will be a
few more videos coming out regarding
Cherno shot but again feel free to
download it if you just want the source
code and you don't want this get not
github nonsense there is a download zip
file you can download that and it will
just give you the the raw source code
files and you won't have to deal with
github at all I know the get is a it's
quite hard and intimidating when you
first started but it really is really
simple so I'd love to make you guys in
videos in regarding of how to [ __ ] this
okay if you want to clone this or
whatever there are videos they'll be in
there in the description below that I've
made already okay I think that's all I
wanted to say so thanks for watching
guys if you did enjoy the series if you
did enjoy this video please hit the like
button below and I'll see you guys next
time goodbye
you